ended up getting in uh maximum security
uh and the riot popped off right two
weeks when when I was in there there was
14 people killed the main boss was
decapitated um and they were playing
basketball in in with this
[Music]
head I was born in the state of Guerrero
in Mexico I was taken to um the us at a
year and a half I was raised in the
South uh Southern
California uh in La Compton a
normal you could say American Childhood
around gang gangs and all that good
stuff that corrupts a kid living in a
South Central Compton a firestone region
it's uh very hectic you know
uh growing up you have to be careful
where you're walking what colors you're
wearing cuz obviously there's a lot of
mugging going on uh Theft Grand Theft
Auto uh gang banging shootouts so it's
you you're under a lot of
stress the majority of the
time how did it kind of happen that you
got involved in in
crime uh growing up in a broken family
um the circumstances of of why my father
went to prison that that pushed me
towards towards gang towards uh
committing crimes I was uh in a way
looking for a way out
um so my father basically he raped my
sister When We Were Young
um the the the stress of seeing that
obligated me to try to uh kill him
stabbed my dad a couple times obviously
I was barely 12 um so I think that's uh
the main reasons why why I was trying to
just get out of my my own world because
of the destruction that my own father
had had
done my father ended up doing 16 years
in avenol state prison left us when we
were really young um my mom being
Mexican and not being able to speak the
language cuz it's uh not easy living in
a country where you don't even know the
language
and uh not having any help from any
family members so that was what U pushed
me into in into crime into gang banging
into hustling for money what kind of
crime was it first and how did it
progress uh first it was home invasions
you know theft normal petty theft um
then it it
it uh moved on to um moving certain
amounts of drugs to different counties
depending on on where the person that
was in charge of the game wanted you to
move them um
anything to gun
crme how old were you that
point
around 14
15 when you're in gangs you you know the
heat that you're you're going to get
yourself involved
um it's a a lot of racial fight fighting
going in going in because at the same
time it's Mexicans against Mexicans and
or other Hispanic uh gangs they kill one
of yours you go looking for one of
them uh that's how I ended up um as a as
a gunslinger or a Hitman well however
you guys want to call it
aario um that's how I got involved in in
gun crimes at that age I was still young
young and stupid
um that's when I decided that you know
what maybe I should try some luck in
Mexico maybe try to get away from gangs
you know get away from the violence
without really understanding what
violence
was I myself took the decision of going
back to Mexico trying to find something
better for me in itself uh at the age of
17 was when I decided to go back to
Mexico obviously it's not the same thing
because culture differences I was uh
raised with chos um mexican-americans
that spoke English that spoke Spanish
going back to Mexico where there's only
Spanish speaking people the culture is
different you know it's a a little bit
harder to uh to involve yourself in
society so you're always looking uh
you're always looking out for people
that look like you that speak like you
and that act like you um that's how I
ended up in
Mexico so what was it like in Mexico uh
it's a whole different world and the
violence uh that the human being is able
to
um to do is is really Unthinkable you
know basically they were doing worse
things that we could never imagine in in
a first world country um and it's more
because of poverty you know of not
trying trying
to become something of themselves making
a name for themselves Cel aloa was uh is
one of the biggest ones in Mexico went
to Sonora and I worked for the senoa as
well a Hitman um I worked in Morelos as
well for for another organization called
lail
mishana and what does a hitman at a
Mexican cartel
do you get you take care of the Dirty
Work you know um obviously they're
always fighting Roots towards the US uh
they're always fighting for
the how can you say this for the
permission of extortion and uh stealing
from the rich in whatever state they're
in um and fighting the enemies you know
that means going into cities and
locating these uh these rival Hitmen
these rival people or rival drug drug
lords and taking them out you have to
understand that the cartels is two
branches the ones that traffic the drugs
and the military uh side of the cartel
as well I went to a location once for
the famar they had a 5 tons of cocaine
uh they also had a la uh how do you call
it how do you say it uh laborator
laboratory laboratory uh of
methamphetamine I've never been towards
that side of uh moving drugs or anything
like that because obviously you're
talking about high quantities of drugs
um I was more addicted to Adrenaline of
of what I could do with the rifle what I
could do with the
pistol
so when you're working as a as a CIO
obviously there's there's rules that you
cannot pass if you want to keep yourself
alive because it's a very dangerous game
um and that was something that was
taught to me since uh since the
beginning uh never get high with
anything that they that they move in
order for you to keep yourself on guard
and on on point on what you're doing um
there's cartels that actually they pay
their their people with drugs especially
cartels that use methamphetamine um
obviously there there's people out there
that will get themselves in debt with
the cartel or with a drug dealer uh they
have no way to pay to paying their debt
and they get pulled in by force um and
they they maintain them with with
crystal meth with cocaine obviously the
people that that would do d drugs you
would see them lasting 3 months 2 months
they would end up getting murdered so
for us as um Saros it would be something
easy to spot the enemy sometimes because
of their drug use uh because of the way
that they would act in uh under stress
or under pressure from the cartels or
from the government I think it's just
more like they're using them as how do
you say
it uh cattle for the slaughter
if you're a professional you know that
what you do is you just put two in the
chest and one in the head that's it it's
better to have them dead than to have
them um to have evidence where the where
the government will be able to
incriminate
you do you feel like in Mexico if you
want to kind of earn money you have
little choice but to get involved with a
cartel you can say in a in a way it is
because obviously a lot of the people
that I met in the
cartels didn't even finish their primary
school you know uh because they didn't
have the resources to to look for better
education and a part it is you know in a
part it's not it's more about the
influence that that Society gives them
you know the
um the type of music that they hear what
what they see on TV that's what they
they feel inspirated to to be like that
and when in reality they have no idea
what um that life is all
about well you have a scared for your
life every day that's how you live
anybody that says that they're not
scared of of that type of life is is
probably lying you know I think uh being
scared is is uh very important in order
for you to keep yourself alive every
time that I would get close to somebody
that person would would get murdered and
and it was a just
a a circle that was not ending so when
talking to people that are in in in this
environment and and when talking to
people that think that they're that
they're gangsters or they're they're
about that life you could tell right
away if they're lying or not just by
asking them what kind of weapon they use
so you can tell when someone is uh is an
expert and you can tell when someone is
is is just bluffing on what they're
saying we have a saying um
you know balls your balls as a man will
get you killed right away so you have to
use the intelligence and you have to use
your balls because obviously that's what
it is you know you can't just be running
around there thinking you're the biggest
and the baddest because there's always
going to be someone bigger or better
than
you is police uh connected to Cel yeah
definitely um local police are 100%
State Police you could say 5050
it's basically the same law that Pablo
Escobar told the government now it's
it's PLO you know it's money or lead
whichever one you want there's seever
there's certain cartels that don't
really give them the option of giving
them money they rather give them lead
and go to war um because obviously it's
uh it's it's more like a gorilla type
war and uh whatever they can acquire
from the
uh State uh government that means rifles
that means life jackets that means
whatever they can take off their dead
bodies they'll take then rather than
give them any money to uh bribe
them what was the most violent thing
you've seen I've seen a lot of violent
things and I would have to
say this time they it was a time where
they picked up like around 12 15 people
not not all of them were were enemies
you know sometimes you're in the wrong
moment at the wrong time and for hanging
around with the wrong crowd you you get
involved and uh there was uh there was
women and and Men um I didn't take part
I was
uh our group had just arrived in the
ranch where this was taking place
another group was obviously kind of
executing was going to execute them but
they were obviously recording everything
to send the message to the rivals um and
they went out with the axis and
chainsaws they dismembered
everybody why would they do that what's
the so basically they want to put out a
message you know maybe this person took
money away from the from the cartel or
they got involved in in in businesses
where they didn't come through um in
order to make sure that other associates
don't follow the same route they put
them as an example once the society or
the the people where where these people
are operating they see several heads
appear in the morning with the big old
message or several pieces of body
scattered around the city then it's easy
for you to go and ask for extortion from
anybody and they they with the fear that
that that might happen to them or to
their family members they will
pay I mean I'll have to ask you what was
the most violent thing you've done
yourself
there's a lot of things um but one in
particular
was I was taking two recruits
um to do a task that was uh given to us
um these recruits obviously were new
they didn't know what they were doing
they got nervous they came back into the
car and they told me that the people
that were there were armed
um we pull up uh near this person and
this person is obviously a rival
um the person in the person in the back
seat I was driving the person in the
back seat uh pulled out a rifle and shot
him he missed a shot but injured him on
the leg
um at this moment the the rifle jammed
the recruit was
panicking I jumped out of the car took
the rifle
um busted the the bullet out and cocked
it back in and I shot him again um this
person was still
agonizing trying to drag himself through
the through the pavement um the rifle
jammed again so I basically went up to
him and and smashed him with the with
the with the butt of the rifle until his
head exploded and uh that was it jumped
back in the car and
left obviously there's more things that
I've done that I but I I just I'm not
willing to discuss at the
moment how many people do you think
you've killed
over I've been in the
game for a long time
um more than 70
probably when we talk about all of those
people killed and tortured have you ever
thought back about them thought about
their families what were your the
motions you were going through you have
to understand that you can't
um you can't take anything personal it's
only a it's only a job you know it's
only it's only business and uh the
moment that you do take it
personal everything goes south there's
definitely some there's honor in it uh I
think that's the only way that you
survive you know that's the only way
that Karma doesn't hit you in your back
is by having honor obviously
honoring the way that how you handle
yourself you know obviously there is
sometimes that you that I think about a
lot of things uh every day you know in
my case
um had no family try to avoid being even
close to anybody that you had any
feelings towards because it it could
have they could use that as
leverage I mean it sounds hering but it
also sounds like quite a lonely
existence I guess it is it
is so I know you went to prison can you
explain how and why you got there yeah
um they had killed someone real close to
me um and I went out of my way to look
for these people and uh get that
situation taken care of uh while I was
in
the in the area where I had taken care
of this these people uh uh I was caught
up by
um state and federal government and uh I
was arrested taken tortured and then
later on informed that I was being
accused of murder in first
degree um that's how I ended up in in
prison and what was the sentence uh they
wanted to give me 30 years of prison for
murder I only did three
years um prison
is is a whole different ball game to
what prisoners in in in the US might uh
might feel that prison is about um a lot
of I've known a lot of um inmates in
Mexico that have been uh felons in the
US and that have spent time uh in
federal prisons and they tell me over
there's a five-star hotel compared to
where we're at now um if you have no
family you have no clothes they don't
give you
squat basically your family has to come
in and drop you off clothes that they uh
obviously ask of a certain color they
have to drop you off toilet paper they
have to drop you of soap shampoo
whatever you need to to to keep yourself
um clean inside a prison your family has
to give to you other than that the
prison system basically makes sure that
you have three meals a day and water
that's all they uh
they they take care of the cells can go
anything from 11 inmates
to I've seen 16 in one cell that is
meant for four people so you're speaking
about having people sleeping on top of
the toilet underneath the the bench that
you have to to have your food uh in the
middle of the of the of the of the what
do you call it the that little space
that you have in the middle of the two
concrete beds and two underneath the
concrete beds a lot of people think that
correctional officers are the ones that
are in charge inside they are not the
ones that are in charge are the inmates
and the cartel that runs the prison
system cuz for every prison that there
is there is a cartel behind it the
guards are sometimes they have no option
you know it's like they're there between
The Sword and the wall if they don't
cooperate with what the cartel wants
then they know that that they're going
to be dealt with outside
um so they try to just keep it chill you
know in the way that they know who not
to mess with and who who they can they
can obviously put their hands on they're
pretty down to earth you know because
obviously they see other co-workers get
killed for trying to oppose the cartel
um what they're doing is they're
basically try just trying to survive and
trying to uh get the best of it because
obviously it's there's a lot of bribery
going on and there's a lot of
prostitution inside of prison as well
with the inmates like with the female
inmates because obviously there's
prisons where there's uh female and male
they're in different sections but the
prison guards they're their their money
is prostituting the female inmates that
are inside
when I ended up in prison um because of
of my of the nature of of of my case and
and for the cartel that I was working
for I was uh privileged to be moved to a
a certain area where I was uh entitled
to several stuff and and obviously I was
given a job that was uh interrogating
any buddy that was coming in for drugs
for homicide for kidnapping
and uh we would go in with the
permission of the security of the
correctional officers uh pull out
smartphones start taking pictures start
interrogating inside of the prison when
I arrived in prison obviously they
promise you the stars that they're going
to get you out that they're going to
help you that they're going to continue
on uh supporting you obviously those are
all
lies what they what they want is
basically they want you to put whoever
you have out there that is loyal to you
as a person because they know who you
are uh keep them working for their
organization um so obviously when I saw
that the that the my case was not
progressing and that I had no benefits
in uh having a lawyer from the cartels
because at the end of the day sometimes
those lawyers are working for someone
else you know so they're not they're not
there to trying they're not there trying
to get you out they're there make to
make sure that you stay in um
so I
basically washed my hands and said you
know what I'm done with you guys I I
with the rivals I ain't with you I just
want to be left in left alone because
obviously my my time here is is going to
be long
um uh They didn't accept that and uh
obviously there was
repercussions
um was being to the degree where I had I
have a broken rib a busted um eardrum
uh when I when I got better I spoke to a
lot of people that were in the prison
with me that were chos and that weren't
they weren't just part of the cartel
they were just chos you know and we made
a riot uh we we we popped the prison
like it's a commonly known um we
murdered we murdered two of them two of
their the their leaders and
uh made a big party um we got
transferred to a State Prison a maximum
security State
Prison and I spent another year and a
half in uh in that prison I think those
were the the most violent ones uh the
prison where I had come from was a
prison of approximately 500 to 600
inmates and I was taken to a prison
where there was 13,000 p uh inmates I
think it's one of
the one of my experiences that I will I
will never forget uh just the amount of
things that I saw inside
um ended up going to M ended up getting
in uh maximum security uh and the riot
popped off right two weeks when when I
was in there um there was 14 people
killed the main boss was
decapitated um and they were playing
basketball in in with his head the anti-
rot uh correction officers came and uh
they knocked on the door on the maximum
security door to try to get in and they
weren't allowed in uh they put all the
dead bodies in in the main entrance and
they told them that there was no
problems inside maximum security that
all they wanted was them to take their
trash for a moment I I started laughing
to myself I was like yeah they're not
they're not going to listen to us they
did they went back the um the people
that lift up the dead bodies and the
criminal investigations came in take the
took their pictures and took the body
all that build up of violence and and
and and memories and and and people that
you love G starts getting to you starts
eating up what you have left of of a
human inside of you you have everything
you know you have money you have drugs
you have women but you don't have peace
you know you start thinking
about what's there to come after you die
cuz you you see people go left and right
and there was occasions where obviously
you're you're in gunfights that last up
to 2 hours hour and a half and you don't
really know if you're going to come out
of those
gunfights so I started questioning
everything you know started questioning
who I was and and and why I was there
and if
um if what I was doing had any any honor
you know if if it was worth dying for I
wasn't about to go back to prison
so mentally I Was preparing myself
to to obviously get murdered you know
and and end my life in in in in in in
combat um but like I said I started
question everything because of the the
level of of stupidity of other
lieutenants and knowing the how the game
works you know you're just a pawn for
for the for the real people that are
making money you they're not going to
worry for you they're not loyal to you
you're just you're just some you're just
something that can be replaced by
something else I think that's when I I
realized that you know what uh I speak
two languages I speak English I speak
Spanish I'm not someone that is stupid
I've been able to survive this long like
there there should be a purpose of of
why I'm still alive cuz in reality I was
I was waiting I was looking for a way
out you know uh I still had bottled up
the emotions of of of living in a
scarred family and especially the trauma
that you go when you see your own father
do something like that like it was
around
January it was cold we were up in the
mountains and in my head I was we were
going in into some conflict with another
Lieutenant that basically wanted to take
what I had so he was trying to get me
killed at the same time and it was
killing the lieutenant and getting into
more problems with the cartel and
running running to another cartel for
asking trying to get help obviously or
it was leaving everything the way it was
you know just leaving everything behind
just got my person out of there and
that's what at the end of the day I did
just left my rifle took my my vest off
left the drugs that we had in the car
left the money that I had in the car uh
stole one of their pickups and just
drove until the gas ran
out
what about your family you talked about
your mom and your siblings are you still
in contact with them yeah yeah I'm in
contact with them I haven't seen my mom
since 17
years that's the last time I saw her 17
years ago so it's been a long
ride by myself um I am in contact with
them you know there was a point
where they didn't really
um we had no
communication when I got in contact with
them it was like now you remember you
have a son you know now you remember you
have a brother like you guys shouldn't
be crying
like we all take our our decis our
decisions and we have to live with our
consequences so if anything happens to
me then don't worry about it let the
dogs eat me cuz that's the life I I
chose that's what I would
say what about your
dad no probably put bullet in his
head if I couldn't when I was younger
when I'm older then definitely you
know what is the future for you what are
you looking forward
to nowadays uh I'm a boxing instructor
because I've always been into Combat
Sports um we have a a group of kids in
Mexico that we help out obviously trying
to give them the best advice to avoid
what one has been through you know
um so for me it's uh if I can put in
any small seat of uh help in order for
uh our future Generations um I rather do
that than anything else than try to like
to make money or or um try to become be
in a better position I'm not worried
about that cuz I've already been there
you know I've had all the money in the
world and doesn't give you anything
you're still empty I've grown up without
a father you know I know the
consequences of of being alone in life
and where it it's led me and I think um
Mexico has that problem that most of the
families are broken up you see kids
running around 300 in the morning 4 in
the morning you know um and sometimes
they just need that extra motivation of
of of um someone that that believes in
them so
that's that's what's there for me right
now there is obviously quite a lot there
do you think this has an impact on you
do you think there's any PTSD or
anything like that yeah I I I suffer of
PTSD um suffering
insomnia um lack of emotion
sometimes uh sometimes they tell me that
I'm very
cold
uh it's all it's something that you
can't just let go out of out of the blue
you know I think it's it takes time to
understand that you're no longer in that
life you know and try to lower your
guard because obviously in that life
you're always with your guard up you
don't really know how to deal with uh
normal
people uh you don't know how to deal
with your family in my case uh it's it's
difficult to just
um try to pretend that all of that stuff
has been left behind when it
hasn't does anything haunt you from all
of those
days I would have to say no because I
know that I have not killed anybody
that's innocent you know obviously if
um I was giving several task to kill
people's mother's people's wife and I
have always objected it because that's
not the person that I
am what's done is done you know and I
think that I wouldn't change anything in
my life because it it makes me the
person that I am
today there's no what if that's an
imaginary
world in
1975 I actually took an oath uh with
five other gentlemen became a sworn ma
member of the family and just to show
you how fortunate I am the Five Guys
that I took the oath with they were all
murdered later on every one of them none
of them survived